my name is Akeem
I look after Google Play business
development for Middle East in Africa
and with me today is a Hugo who's going
to come up on stage in a couple of
minutes to talk about maleo games a very
successful game develop out of Lagos
Nigeria who develops specifically titles
for emerging markets out of an emerging
markets so today you're going to hear a
lot of designated content that speaks to
to growth in user acquisition and to
device penetration but with this talk we
would like to invite you to think about
the next billion users and where they're
going to come from particularly with
regards to user growth so we've seen
astounding development in the last
couple of years I'm sure we all have
highly capable devices in our pockets we
have high speed data connections that
are always on and the data you pay for
today is pretty much a lot cheaper than
it was just two three or four years ago
but every now and again it's important
to really take a moment and reflect what
has happened over the last couple of
years that got us to this point and see
how we can take those learnings to
really continue and accelerate that
growth over the next coming years again
particularly with regards to user growth
so again today we will be talking about
building high quality games and apps
that work effectively not only for the
user of today but for the users of the
next coming years and so we've seen
tremendous growth from emerging markets
and we projected about 80 percent of
smartphone growth globally it's going to
come from emerging markets by 2010 2019
and as more users get access to these
devices they get connected for the first
time and the first time making any
experiences with the web they will be
looking for new ways to experience the
internet to shop to entertain themselves
to communicate and that itself is
bringing up a massive opportunity for
all of us in this room so again 80
percent of smartphone growth up until
2019 will be coming from emerging
markets so what's important here is to
then look at the challenges this users
face and to start designing it
theory answers that will cater to these
challenges I'm backing this up with
numbers from google play that Mark
referenced in this early keynote today
we see a tremendous increase in an
accelerated growth in downloads as well
as in consumer spend for emerging
markets and we don't see any indication
that this is going to stop anytime soon
so if you compare emerging markets with
developed markets we see significantly
faster growth just about four times as
fast while consumers spend is double and
we expect us to further grow it's an
exciting trend and it's important to
realize that this is happening yet put
this in context and see where this
growth is actually coming from so first
we all know fast networks are awesome we
all have instant information instant
capabilities in our pockets today but if
you look at the reality of today still
just about half of mobile internet usage
is coming from a 2g connection and I'm
sending out an open question into this
room when was the last time you were in
a 2g connection when was the last time
you actually opened your own game or app
from a 2g connection if you extrapolate
this out and project what's going to
happen until 2020 we'll still expect one
in three users to be or just about one
in three users to be on 2g and that that
resembles about 1 billion users so
definitely a massive opportunity but
again with different challenges that
need to be addressed accordingly for
example if you look at the variation of
network speed and the availability of
networks just across the board you can
see for example here India under on the
center-right average speed of Indian and
of Indian usage Indian internet usage
partner is about 1/10 of that in the UK
while the quality of the adoption of
high-speed networks is very low just
about one in five or 20% of broadband
connections are above 4 megabytes per
second so again data availability being
very scarce and the speeds once you get
there are very low so these users behave
significantly different from the users
today finally another one of key
challenges in emerging markets is the
data cost data is expensive in a lot of
these markets and they're just about to
down in prices just look at comparative
data here that actually looks at the
comparative data cost as relative to the
gross income of a of a median household
and you can see that a data plan in
Nigeria is about 10 times as much
relative to the UK so again these users
are super sensible to how data has been
consumed from your app and being good
stewards of their data plan is just
appreciated and good business so with
that in mind we want to help and drive
the engagement in those regions and to
support the growth in these markets
we've created a framework which we call
the next billion and it's centered
around six key topics which I will
outline and very briefly now and
reference some resources where you can
read up in a lot more detail about these
these elements so without further ado if
you're looking at the six pillars that
we invite you to take a look at its
connectivity device compatibility data
cost battery consumption content and
commerce and again I'm going to cover
everything very briefly we're going to
be here all afternoon if you want to
speak in any of about any of those in
more detail so connectivity by the way
we just wanted to outline this is by no
means just the best practice for
emerging markets these are good
practices and good principles to
implement even for the users today so
connectivity you wanna sure smooth
loading of your smooth loading of your
content you should prioritize your
bandwidth requests to make sure that the
top requests are served first that the
most useful and relevant information is
loaded at the beginning for example
loading text before you loading images
don't duplicate your network and request
and save files locally where applicable
you could use the connectivity manager
which is actually a gun' navigate VI
that gives you feedback on what kind of
connectivity you should expect from from
this device and then change your app
serving accordingly images are typically
the biggest perpetrators of often slow
load time there's no connectivity so
and invite you to think about the
standards of the images you load which
formats which resolution you're actually
load and where it becomes relevant and
make sure that you're using the
appropriate sizes of those images lastly
with regards to connectivity I encourage
you all to look at how your app in-game
performs in an offline environment just
go ahead turn your phone into airplane
mode open up your app and see what
happens see where it actually finds bugs
see where it actually gets stuck and
what experiences you need to improve to
assure a good offline experience moving
on to device compatibility it's a huge
range of devices with big screen small
screens expandable storage small storage
high density screens and so forth
and so it's I guess all of us faced the
issue of developing an app in the game
that can really run on all of these
devices so you should look at what
competitor what capacity your app is
actually invoking and then optimize for
that keep in mind that a lot of these
devices that we're talking about are
still one megabyte in ROM and below and
so and you should think about how your
app actually runs in these kind of
environments and games should be
optimized to render smoothly in those
kinds of environments then look at
screen sizes as I mentioned these are
these devices that are coming on and are
likely to be low cost and they are
likely to be longer in there in their
life cycles and you want to make sure
that you have your your exposure tested
on different screen sizes screen
resolution and pixel densities and any
mentioned before that the new emulator
in Android studio is vastly improved
it's increased in speed and it allows
you to test very quickly for these
elements so changing the device
resolution and the device size just as
an example why would you load a
high-resolution image on a low
resolution device that's just you know a
lot of waste in a many different factors
moving on to efficient memory usage and
users see that screen at all time they
can get a push notification when the
memory is running out and they can
actually see a sorted list of how much
memory and how much storage your apps
are actually using and so here's the pro
tip for this one you can use the API
call of is low ramp and actually get
feedback in real time to figure out if
this is a highly capable device or a low
capable device and then change your
processes accordingly also background
processing background processing is
typically what drives up a lot of the
storage live and in it on the user's
device and that's perfectly fine many
apps may invoke processes in the
background but you should be good
stewards of your users device memory and
you want to start up your background
processors finish them try to bundle
them into one round and then shut down
the process in order not to drain and a
user's memory as well as the battery
moving on to smart storage think about
installing or just running this one line
of code that allows users to push their
apps onto their SD card then this can go
a long way for for devices with
expandable storage and as I mentioned
before users can actually sort how much
them data is consumed in how much space
is consumed on your phone and can see
the list of the most draining apps on
top which will then drive a lot of the
uninstall and install rates up so you
want to keep your device consumption low
and make sure that you are frequently
clearing the cache that you're creating
and this one is a tip that I'm sure
you're not going to hear often today so
this is the one and only time I guess
you will hear this today but think about
backwards compatibility think about and
these new users coming online with
slightly older devices and not
necessarily always on the latest version
of Android so I'd invite you to run your
apps with the minimum SDK 14 about the
target SDK 23 in order to really care
to a wide variety of users that are
being kept with the latest features also
think about integrating the Google Play
services API because we will ensure that
users get updates on time and make and
we will make sure that the users are
catered to with the features that
actually work for their devices moving
on and I'm already finishing off so if
you go get ready
well it's your it's your time to speak
in a minute I'm looking at data cost as
we said before data is expensive in
these countries and it's only very
slowly becoming cheaper we're used to
having cheap always-on data but the
reality is about half of users don't
have that privilege today installing
your app is an actual cost to the user
and think about how real power sizable
your apk actually is how much space and
how much data usage the users actually
going to consume by just downloading
your app if you have a prepaid package
for 200 megabytes a month how likely are
you to actually download a game that is
a hundred megabyte on a unfree data so
again think about your apk size and
there's a great talk from Google i/o
which I encourage you to take a look at
it's called put your apk on the diet and
definitely worth checking out
the sweet spot for emerging markets is
around ten megabytes that's what you
should be aiming for we see a high
drop-off with every megabyte that you
add in weight now I realize for a lot of
the game developers in this room this is
you know this number is completely
unreasonable building a high quality 3d
game in ten megabytes is very tricky and
often times the third-party libraries
you're using on their own already
exceeding those ten megabytes so if you
can't make this number work and December
sounds completely unreasonable to you
consider multi apk launching multiple
apks into different device categories
just to make sure that you can cater to
those users as well so again users a
sense of sensitive to make the case
sizes images as we noted before are the
biggest offenders with this you want to
reduce cost and you want to consider
multi apk and to service again and
Android studio and firebase analytics
allows you to test and see how much data
your apps
consuming you can benchmark the data and
and being again good stewards of this
data will go a long way with the users
moving to battery consumption you want
to eliminate unnecessary wake-ups
you want to batch your network requests
whenever they come in and you want to
use the network manager API again which
can give you feedback on what kind of
network is expected and moving on to
content users everywhere want tailored
content we notice from our own data and
we're looking at Google Play and we
optimize it for different scenarios and
highlighting and servicing specific
tailored content for a local audience we
see significant improvements in adoption
adoption and engagement so localization
is important think about fast responsive
UIs think about that a UI best practices
which we talked about today material
design and these are all these are all
best practices to really cater to a user
in a in a local environment to make sure
that they feel at home and that they
feel that this environment is tailored
for their use last but not least
Commerce we all strive to make this a
business and not just a fun exercise so
catering to those markets you want to
adjust them you wanna adjust your
monetization strategy accordingly
there's multiple different ways of
driving revenue from these markets
obviously users are more sensitive to
price but you want to use em you want to
use multiple different monetization
schemes to really figure out what works
best some of which might be best catered
to with in-app purchases while other
markets are specifically more
susceptible to ad revenue so when
driving and when driving different ways
we want to make Google Play a commerce
platform for you and enable enable good
businesses in those regions as well so
think about the barrier of entry where
do you want to charge at what levels and
and what price points do you want to
charge for your content and and offer
prizes in local currency and we've just
referred to earlier about and pricing
templates I encourage you to use those
and to make sure that your prices are
adjusted you
the local currency at the right numbers
and in addition to that you should also
take a look at the Big Mac index the
purchasing power of a single dollar in a
single country if you multiply that with
the prices you're actually charging you
automatically become more sensible to
that local market because you're
charging something that is actually
equivalent towards them to what users
can afford so I'm summarizing the points
we've made earlier and again there's a
lot of resources which I'll share them
after Hugo's talk and on how to really
look at these best practices figure out
which ones are relevant for you and then
go out and implement them but if there's
three main in pieces of information that
I would like to to share today and to
encourage you to take home with you
after this talk is that 1 billion users
will still be on 2g by 2020 the average
mobile data speed in Vietnam India
Argentina Brazil is below 4 megabytes
per second and the relative cost of data
in emerging market is about 10 times
higher compared to that in the UK so
think about fast apps that are reliable
and lightweight in order to best cater
for the next billion users and leverage
that growth going forward with that and
I would like to observe it was the wrong
button I would like to invite Hugo Obi
from earlier games to speak about his
experience developing for merchants
hi so it's a real pleasure to be here
today as Aiki said my name is sugar OB
I'm from Malaya Games in Lagos Nigeria
we build locally relevant games
primarily for the Nigerian market our
vision is to share the African narrative
with the world through games I'm just
show of hands who has been to the
African continent before excellent and
secondly who's been to Nigeria before
fantastic a few people in the room so
you would understand how unique this
part of the world is in terms of
connectivity so I just you know run
through a little bit of a background
about Africa I talk a little bit about
Nigeria and then like we're going to go
dive in a little bit into a specific you
guess user segmentation that I think
would hopefully enable you understand a
little bit better about the kinds of
people that you'll be targeting if you
decide to come into a market like
Nigeria so most of my time was spent
talking about Nigeria well firstly in
terms of like Africa as a continent um
you know some people still think it's a
single country but obviously we have
about 54 countries in the continent it's
got a lot of language is there but the
population is very large but the
connectivity in terms of people who
actually connected to the internet as
you can see from here is about twenty
one point twenty eight point one percent
of people who connected this is a mobile
first market which means that a lot of
people who connect to the internet
actually experience that connection via
mobile devices so tablets computers and
not as prevalent as mobile devices are
so in terms of ninety and I guess a very
very large market we just under two
hundred million people in terms of
population and you with the second
largest economy in the continent but
what is really really interesting is
that we have a lot of mobile
connectivity at least I compared to
everybody else so we're just under 100
million people who connected Internet
Muslim via mobile devices in terms of
people who actually have access to
mobile mobile phones or the number of
mobile lines that we have in the
continent in the countries about 200
million so a lot of people have dual
devices draw SIM cards and people are
connected using multiple devices but
what what I'm really excited about
sharing today is to use the segmentation
which I touched on earlier we've been
able to identify four unique kludgy
custom segments in Nigeria and this
customer segments actually divide
defined by their connectivity so how
they actually connect to the internet
more than anything else but look at an
idea as a broad market what is really
interesting from a social angle is I
don't know if you guys are familiar with
Nollywood is the third largest movie
movie industry in the world behind
behind so Hollywood and Bollywood of
course from India and it's actually the
second largest contributor to our GDP
after oil and gas so a huge employer of
people and the locals are believed EDM
keen on their local movies our music is
actually very huge exports so there's a
lot of people music coming from Nigeria
which is I am doing across different
parts of the continent in Africa and
obviously a huge export here in the West
as well so when you go to clubs and bars
in most popular cities you are more
likely to come across one of our music's
football is huge at its second to
religion in Nigeria we are fanatics when
it comes to football we love our
Premiership we love our La Liga and you
know there was this story about these
two Nigerians who got into a massive
fight over which footballer was the best
football in the world
Linna messy or Cristiano Ronaldo so we
don't take it very likely religion like
I said is you know that's like pretty
much every street in Nigeria has a
church so I watched it a little clip
recently that showed that the top 10
richest pastors depending on what
denomination you are but the top 10
which has passed us in the world five of
them on
four of whom are actually in Nigeria so
that's by the fact that we do have huge
economic challenges people are very
generous when it comes to church and
then fashion is sort of like becoming a
modern trend and this is huge adoption
for you know like fashion design people
are very you know interested in what
they wear and are shopping for these
kind of things politically the weighted
opportunities I mean this is like
opportunities and challenges at the same
time but like politically what the
government is really interested in is on
education so education is a huge
challenge for the content so any sort
like apps that enable people to learn on
the go on their mobile device is
actually a very huge hit and then
anything around empowerment is also very
huge hit because the government has a
very large youth population and you know
getting these people educated and giving
them access to like employment
opportunities actually a huge challenge
for them on the mobile side you know
Nigeria has huge infrastructure problems
so I actually came to London via Cape
Town and in Cape Town they have me like
in South Africa they occasionally have
something called load shedding which is
where people you know for a couple of
hours in a day the government is like
distributing power between the different
districts so people are possible for you
to actually lose power for a couple of
hours in a day and Nigeria is a
completely different thing I mean like
there's nothing this new such a solution
and it's just power outage and this is
probably what about 80 90 percent of the
time for those of you who's been to
Nigeria is a huge huge problem which
means that battery battery life is
actually usually important to mobile
users most people have battery and power
packs that they that they use with their
mobile phones but that is not sufficient
internet like I said earlier is
extremely expensive and that is
something that people are very conscious
about there is not a lot of transparency
between the internet service providers
and the actual end consumers in terms of
what their data is being used for so
you're more you know you can buy a data
bundle of maybe two two gigs and it can
run out in a couple of hours and people
don't have a huge understanding as to
how the data is actually being utilized
for the amount of money pain free petrol
communication
a massive because of you know voice
voice and data costs so people adopt
these products to enable them to keep in
touch with friends and family and then
Internet connectivity speed source
unless you're challenged and this is you
know around the infrastructure
difficulties for a lot of the telcos and
Internet service writers in the country
but so let's I'm gonna dive into the
different user segments so um earlier
I'd touched on before user segment so if
you're bringing a product into Nigeria
you're looking at the Nigerian market
these are four unique categories of
users based on their connectivity so we
have what what I will return does
they're always on arm segment now these
guys are pretty much the types of people
that you would expect to meet in any
developed market the well-educated most
of them actually have some level of
foreign education the well-traveled
they have the earn decent salary by
nature standards they connect to the
internet via multiple devices what they
really care about is connection speed
more than price prices not really
they're not as price sensitive they
access their content via the app stores
they have multiple payment options so
they can update their very comfortable
paying with credit cards and debit card
so using payment platforms like PayPal
because they've lived abroad and they're
they understand the security benefits or
the convenience benefits of actually
doing transactions online you know you
would find them using apps like uber
snapped YouTube they huge video
consumers and they play games that
require you to be connected when you're
playing so they're not too bothered
about that so that's the very first
group I represent over five percent of
the market the second group is what we
tagged as the mostly on group so data
costs obviously very expensive and this
is all like the kinds of people who you
know swap between being online and
offline and this is kind of like trying
to trying to manage the data that they
they have access to or they can afford
they usually connect using either a
phone or tablet PCs are not you know we
don't have a lot of like freak landlines
or cable connections so most people are
connecting using some kind of like my
five device or some kind of router on
obviously the 3G connect connections
again these guys I saw like reasonably
educated they are employees and employed
individuals they typically purchase data
bundles so there is kinda like some kind
of cap around what the bias will do like
a four gig plan or five gate plan or 10k
plan value for 30 days so obviously the
very conscious of what they're using
their data to consume so they typically
use apps that enable them some kind of
like offline access as well as like
online access their huge users of like
communication tools and play you know
they have access to games as well they
access their games directly from the app
stores as well there because of the
level of education they understand how
to use stores like Google Play the next
group is our on-demand group so this
group is kind of like where you start to
see a lot more people who are spend more
time offline and they do online and they
usually access the internet using
product bundles so what product bundles
do is that there is a basket of
applications that you can get unlimited
access to over a thirty day period and
so they'll be like your communication
tools your instruments your social tools
your instant messaging tools your
emailing tools and this is what they
would typically pay for so the access to
the Internet is actually limited I mean
that they might not necessarily be able
to use a browser or access YouTube in
the same way that they could actually
use Facebook Twitter or Instagram folks
like this typically have one device so
they usually access connections via
their phone this is now where you start
to see a lot more people who are using
like very low end phones or you know
fairly second-hand phones actually are
also very popular for this group in
terms of payments they they're not very
comfortable using cards or using any
form or any payment platforms so they
would do direct
a billion for payment you know they're
more comfortable paying with cash and in
terms of how they access content for
their mobile devices they would
typically do use file sharing file
sharing applications to access pretty
much access applications offline I don't
know if you guys are familiar with
Zender but sender is a very popular
application for this for this group and
then the last group that we're going to
look at is you know where majority of
the population actually falls into from
our analysis and we run about 75% of the
population falls into this group so this
is like your self-employed your artisans
they're mostly uneducated again like
they would access the Internet we have
product bundles or you know limited
price plans but most of the times
actually offline they're now using like
you know really really blue and feature
phones there's a lot of a lot of Chinese
manufacturers engine to the market we
like with a really basic basic devices
for the select segment in terms of like
how they access the apps they when they
go to the markets to purchase the phones
there are there are people in the
markets that actually install the
absolutely paid to actually have apps
installed so this group is more likely
not to be familiar with app stores and
you know the solar freedom that they can
actually have with access in the app
stores on their own in terms of their
top apps you're more likely to see them
using browsers like Oprah which allows
them to actually get faster speed - so
like you know get access to the internet
without necessarily utilizing like a
huge level of bandwidth so when so the
last thing I want to touch on is like
this kind like matrix of like how all of
these things are so like connected to
like the design principles for the next
billion users so in terms of like
connectivity you know there's a lot of
our wareness around the fact that most
of the people who are going to be
accessing the Internet's of using like
2g 3G connections a lot of people are
going to be using low-end smartphones
and feature phones and some in some
instances
for internet connection of other like
connectivity it's going to be mostly
around like PS you do some kind of pay
as you go limited put a bundle package
we still be using so yeah I mean like
that's that's kind of like my my talks
on the subject thank you very much
you